the EU has gun controls in its
line-of-sight trying to push through
Parliament stricter controls on museums
and collectors on buying firearms online
and marking parts the idea to limit the
ability of terrorists and criminals to
rebuild deactivated weapons and shift
them across borders when I impossibility
plumb national me blah Makita impede the
renewal pen quality her not be during
European or now in Europe that
possibility is a trip to your father who
is the [ __ ] easy
on Tuesday the internal Market Committee
invited leading experts to a hearing
into the impact of legislation proposed
by the Commission and prompted by last
year's attacks in France few were happy
neither so the committee chair who
described it as poorly drafted if we
were to just pass the Commission's
proposals unamended they would have
significant impacts on museums
collectors historians let alone sports
and hunting interests and let alone the
military reserve in some countries so we
need to work to amend those proposals
any peas want a better balance between
the fight against terrorism and the
rights of those with a legitimate case
to hold firearms